flying is expensive why is this well
most would say it's because the cost of
fuel but that's not entirely true
the Airbus a320neo can carry six
thousand four hundred gallons of fuel
that's the equivalent of three hundred
and seventy six fully tank Toyota Camrys
for every mile that the a320 flies it
burns a 1.5 gallons of jet fuel that
works out to a paltry point six seven
miles per gallon an a320 could barely
fly from the Empire State Building to
Grand Central Terminal on that gallon of
fuel to fly that 213 miles from New York
to DC that a320 needs 317 gallons of
fuel with that amount our Toyota Camry
could drive from New York to LA 49 times
but we do have to consider that a Camry
only seats 5 on a 320 seat 154 so
assuming that our plane is fully loaded
it now has a per-person fuel efficiency
of a hundred and four point seven miles
per gallon that's amazing according to
the Bureau of Transport Statistics
Airlines pay on average only one dollar
and twenty four cents per gallon of fuel
so flying from New York to DC you
personally only use two dollars and
fifty cents worth of fuel so why do
these tickets cost upwards of $80 well
there's so much more that goes into your
ticket price and fuel before we start
I'll quickly mention that these are all
rough estimates many of these prices
will vary widely through time and there
are certainly ways that airlines reduce
these costs but this will give you a
general idea of what actually makes
flying so expensive the first thing we
can add to our ticket price is crew
costs a pilot makes on average around
seventy nine thousand dollars a year
which works out to about forty four
dollars per flight hour we have two
pilots so for our hour-long flight from
New York to DC that's $88 to the pilots
a fully loaded a320 requires four flight
attendants who are each paid around $38
per flight hour for a total of 152
dollars bringing our crew costs up to
240 dollars so with our 154 seats that
works out to just about a dollar and 50
cents per person in crew costs all right
now we're at four dollars
next we got to pay the airport's New
York's John F Kennedy Airport charges
six dollars and 33 cents per thousand
pounds of airplane taking off and our
a320 weighs one hundred and seventy two
thousand pounds that means that we have
to give a thousand and eighty nine
dollars to JFK or seven dollars per
person Dulles Airport doesn't publish
their landing fees but we'll assume it's
about the same as JFK's landing fees at
one thousand five dollars for a now one
hundred and seventy thousand pound
airplane these fees generally include
the cost of using gates Porter's and
other airport resources and divided down
to $13.50 per person our total is now at
$17.50 now we get to the fun part taxes
there's a litany of different taxes and
they all vary by country so for the sake
of simplicity we'll just cover the ones
for the u.s. the simplest tax is the
domestic passenger ticket tax at seven
point five percent of the ticket price
that money goes to the FAA if you land
or take off at a rural Airport which is
defined as an airport with less than a
hundred thousand employments or the
second preceding calendar year and
either one is not locate within 75 miles
of another Airport with 100,000
claimants per year to is receiving
central air service subsidies or three
is not connected by pave roads to
another Airport
they also tack on another 7.5% that of
course doesn't apply to either of our
airports the FAA also charges four
dollars flat for any flight within the
u.s. unless you go to Hawaii or Alaska
then they charge eight dollars and
seventy cents the tsa then adds a five
dollar and sixty cent tax called the
9/11 security fee that goes to fund the
heightened security since 9/11 those are
only just for domestic flights if we
were flying from New York to Paris we
would also have to add 17 dot 70 cents
for the international transportation tax
five dollars and fifty cents for the US
Customs user fee five dollars for the US
Animal and Plant Health Inspection
Service fee seven dollars the US
Immigration and Naturalization fee and
fourteen dollars for the French civil
aviation tax so with all the taxes and
fees that apply to this short flight
we're now at 33 dollars total now let's
remember that airplanes are expensive
our a320 cost 107 million
dollarz the service lifer airplanes is
not actually determined by flying time
it's determined by something called
flight cycles which is basically a fancy
word for one flight it doesn't really
matter how long an airplane flies in its
service life what matters is how many
times it's pressurized this is because
every time it's pressurized micro-cracks
develop around the rivets that connect
the metal plates that make up the
fuselage no matter if a plane goes on a
30-minute flight or a nine-hour flight
the wear and tear to the plane will be
the same this is why large long-haul
airplanes are often older they might
only go through one flight cycle per day
while small regional jets could go
through eight or ten so back to our a320
our plane is actually a pretty durable
aircraft it can fly up to 60,000 cycles
so if we divide the total price of our
plane by the maximum number of flight
cycles we get that one thousand seven
hundred and eighty three dollars per
flight must be devoted towards paying
off the initial price of the airplane
per person that works out to $11.50
we're now at forty four dollars and
fifty cents to keep this plane safe
airlines have to also perform regular
maintenance for our hour-long flight an
airline has to do maintenance that'll
cost six hundred and forty six dollars
in labor two hundred and seventy six
dollars in parts six hundred and three
dollars in inspections and component
overhauls and another five hundred
ninety six dollars in engine restoration
that's two thousand one hundred and
twenty one dollars total or fourteen
dollars per person we're now at fifty
eight dollars and fifty cents we also
have to consider the non-flying part of
flying overseeing any flight is an
airline which is a business that has
costs in and of itself they need to pay
administrators executives software
engineers marketers consultants customer
service personnel public relations
agents janitors along with rent benefits
travel costs utilities and more it's
hard to put an exact number on how much
per person this works out to but we'll
make a conservative estimate of ten
we're up to $68.50 an airline will pay
about a hundred and six thousand five
hundred dollars per year for insurance
for an a320 and assuming our plane
spends eight hours per day in the air
thirty-six dollars of this insurance is
for this hour-long flight or about
twenty-five cents per person our very
rough grand total is sixty eight dollars
and seventy five cents well round this
up to seventy dollars since there are
various small things that in cover such
as hotel costs for crew members clean
storage APU rental liability insurance
etc that means that ten dollars of our
plane ticket is profit but keep in mind
that all my estimates were on the
conservative end and it's all assuming a
fully loaded airplane in the end not a
ton of money actually goes to the
airline back to my first line flying is
expensive well it really isn't and it's
getting cheaper to fly in the magic
metal bird across the country from New
York to LA in six hours costs around
three hundred and forty dollars
round-trip to drive in our very
fuel-efficient Toyota Camry across the
country in 40 hours cost three hundred
and forty dollars Justin fuel than an
additional three hundred dollars in
estimated maintenance and depreciation
costs in the past thirty years the
average inflation adjusted airfare has
dropped by 50% and it's still dropping
in 1974 it was actually illegal for
Airlines to offer a flight between New
York and LA for less than one thousand
four hundred and forty two inflation
adjusted dollars and now you can
sometimes find these flights for less
than $200 roundtrip one of the reasons
for this drop in prices is the rise of
efficient airplanes certain innovations
such as composite construction better
aerodynamics more efficient engines and
perhaps most notably winglets has driven
down the cost of flying here's the one
and only real engineering to explain
winglets as you said the airline
industry is constantly finding ways to
drive down their fuel consumption in the
early 70s fuel prices skyrocketed and
engineers are forced to find ways of
making their planes more efficient one
way they found was with winglets which
are those little curly bits at the end
of the wing let's have a quick look at
how they work
winglets were introduced to decrease
induced drag which occurs when high
pressure air below the wing begins to
bleed over the edge
into the low-pressure air above this
flow creates vortices off the tips of
the wing that create drag and reduce
lift which reduces the fuel economy of
the plane winglets act to reduce these
vortices by reducing the airflow over
the edge of the wing for a full
explanation and a look at the history
behind winglets head over to my channel
and watch my new video which features a
special guest appearance from Wendover
productions thanks real engineering be
sure to go check out and subscribe to
real engineering's channel if you like
this channel I guarantee you'll enjoy
his I'll leave you with the real reason
specific air fares are expensive but
also reason why they're getting cheaper
competition the airline industry is one
with very little competition air fares
from New York to LA are cheap because
there's a lot of demand and there's a
relatively high amount of competition
five different airlines fly direct from
New York to LA two of which are budget
airlines people don't care that much
which airline they fly they care about
the price so airlines will try to match
the price of budget airlines compare
this to a route like Denver to Gunnison
County Airport largely because only
United makes this flight you'll often
pay more than $500 for this 130 mile
flight so that's why your plane tickets
cost so much
next time you book your travel you'll
know why you're paying so much and also
how little that actually goes to
Airlines thank you for watching if you
enjoyed this video make sure to clip
subscribe you can also click here to be
taken to real engineering's channel if
you enjoyed this video please share it
on Twitter reddit Facebook stumble upon
take whatever website you like you can
check out last week's video on an
illegal number here also please follow
me on twitter at Wendover pro lastly i'd
like to thank you all for your support
and welcome all the new subscribers from
the past few weeks next week I'll be
back to my normal series that Wikipedia
list